à moscou et ça souligne la signification
particulière que nous donnons au
développement de nos relations
bilatérales
nous avons parlé en détail d'un certain
nombre de questions et nous avons un
banc a souligné sur ce l'intérêt commun
que cela représente de remporter
renforcer concrètement est pratiquement
la noce discussions bilatérales
pour étendre notre coopération en
matière en matière culturelle de
formation
universitaire et aussi sur les plans
religieux entre
c'est puisque ces relations sont très
anciens d'abord parce que l'église
orthodoxe de russie
coopèrent de façon très étroite avec ses
collègues libanais surtout de ses
orientations
nous avons tout un ensemble de textes
juridiques
et deux traités de coopération
et tout cela fait aussi que nos
intervenants économiques participent
aussi à tout ce travail il est la
question de l'explosion
le 4 août 2020 dans le port de beyrouth
est d'ailleurs le gouvernement libanais
nous avait demandé des éléments que nous
avons fourni aujourd'hui justement donc
ce sont des images satellite de ce qui
s'est passé et cela pourra donc aider au
déroulement de l'enquêté sur les causes
c'est une question qui attire une grande
intention aujourd'hui au liban et nous
espérons bien que
cette aide que nous apporte que nous
apportons permettra de clore cette
enquête en plus de cela nous avons parlé
aussi des efforts communs
notamment la présence de nos sociétés
russes rosteig par exemple sur le
développement du secteur énergétique
les ban est notamment sur le plateau
continental avec
des l'extraction et la mise en place
d'un terminal de conservation
de produits pétroliers détenus par
rosneft et nous remettrons remercions
nos collègues pour toutes les
informations fournies sur la situation
au liban notamment étant donné la
dimension multi confessionnel de la
société libanaise et tout cela c'est
important et cela rentre aussi dans le
calcul de l'établissement de la paix
dans la région nous avons confirmé comme
nous le faisons constamment notre
attachement à l'indépendance et à
l'intégrité territoriale du pays
considère que c'est le pays lui-même
qu'il doit résoudre toutes les questions
d'aménagement de l'état et toutes les
questions générales d'ordre national
doivent se faire d'offre être résoudre
par le dialogue sur la base de la
constitution dans le respect mutuel et
la recherche de compromis et j'ai vu que
monsieur le ministre avait cette
intention justement il représente le
gouvernement mikati qui a été formé
récemment qui est un gouvernement de
coalition
et qui datent donc de septembre et nous
espérons donc cela aura achevé cette
longue période
d'incertitude et dans la crise les
bananes et nous avons donc bon espoir et
de bonnes raisons de croire que son
équipe permettra de stabiliser la
situation dans le pays et de mettre fin
à cette crise de longue durée est de
faire en sorte que toutes les structures
de l'état fonctionne nous avons parlé
aussi de l'actualité internationale
régionale nos positions sont très
proches voire concordent parfaitement
la situation toujours difficile
exposition certains points et nous
sommes convaincus que le liban ne doit
pas être
considérée comme un point d'ingérence
extérieure
je sais que des efforts dans cette
direction défendre sont faites sont
faits dans ce sens et je pense que cela
est mortifère tant pour le gouvernement
que libanais que pour la situation
régionale
et le liban ne doit pas servir à
d'autres pays pour que ceux-ci règlent
leurs comptes et bien évidemment nous
sommes contre le fait que ce pays se
trouve otage dans la crise autour de la
syrie et c'est pour cela que nous
constatons maintenant certain nombre de
tendances positives
sur la base des accords qui ont été
conclus
il ya notamment la question
d'alimentation électrique venant de
jordanie de gaz venant d'égypte
et là je pense encore une fois que c'est
une étape importante qui montre qu'on va
quand même dans la bonne direction on
cherche à mettre en place les fondements
des fondements économiques stables qui
permettent de résoudre les problèmes
politiques nous avons parlé aussi
des moyens de renforcer la coopération
entre la russie et le liban pour le
retour des libanais
2 le retour des syriens qui se sont
réfugiés les bains au liban pour qu'il
puisse revenir dans leur pays et je
voudrais que la communauté
internationale soit attentive à cette
question et que le problème des réfugiés
syriens au liban
et que les efforts et les contributions
internationales se soient orientés à la
reconstruction au sein de la libye
justement pour que les réfugiés qui sont
au liban turquie en est j'ai pu se
revenir comme aujourd'hui
la plus grande coopération la plus
grande contribution pardon qui a été
fait ici est justement fait pour
entretenir des camps de réfugiés à
l'extérieur de la syrie je ne pense pas
que ce soit une solution
donc ce qu'il faut ici c'est obtenir le
retour des réfugiés dans leurs foyers
monsieur le ministre m'a gentiment
invité à me rendre les bancs et j'ai
accepté gentil chaleureusement cette
invitation je vous remercie
d'avoir présenté un dossier concernant
la fête
nationale vous savez que le liban
traverse une situation économique est
très difficile et nous espérons que la
coopération avec la russie va favoriser
la résolution de nos problèmes en terre
l'euro à l'agglo cadeaux liés à la
criminalité
cela
m'a
souri
aujourd'hui mais cela vaut également
partager la position de la russie sur
nombre de problèmes internationaux et
régionaux sur tout ce qui est incertain
pour le liban c'est le problème de la
série la russie a toujours soutenu la
stabilité la souveraineté et la sécurité
de ce pays qu'il faut concerne également
le liban
l'une des orientations importantes de
notre coopération c'est le retour des
réfugiés syriens je vis dans la batterie
je parle de ceux qui ont trouvé refuge
au liban après le début de la guerre si
nous
[Musique]
saluons également les efforts russe pour
organiser les situation en syrie comme
un flic et concernant d'autres conflits
régionaux qui en france d'une manière
négative
situation antérieure au niveau de jeu
car nous
[Musique]
avons
fait
ce qui concerne les relations
bilatérales
en tout je voudrais remercier la partie
russe d'avoir envoyé des photos par
cette lise par satellite faites le jour
de l'explosion qui s'est déroulé dans le
port de beyrouth sans aucun doute ces
données nous permettront de en kit et
d'une manière claire sur ce qui est
arrivé
notre côté nous avons partagé son point
de vue sur la situation à l'intérieur du
liban notamment en ce qui concerne avant
tout le conflit de longue durée et c'est
ptet situation économique cette crise
sociale économique auquel fait face
notre pays actuellement nous avons
également discuté des mesures à prendre
pour résoudre cette crise et
puis
ces mesures comprennent la coopération
du liban avec la fonds monétaires le
fonds monétaire international
et le rôle de la russie est clé dans ce
contexte là parce que la russie est l'un
des pays président du font de leur mieux
faire
nous avons également évoqué les réformes
seront entreprises au liban
avoir l'aide internationale ces réformes
considérons comme celui touché l'énergie
le domaine bancaire et le secteur privé
nous avons également débattu
la base législative de notre coopération
bilatérale et de citer le camp
nous avons également noté c'est une
coopération fructueuse dans le cadre de
missions internationales
plus j'ai invité monsieur l'aof à
visiter pour voir personnellement les
efforts que notre pays entreprend pour
mettre fin à la crise
je voudrais remercier encore une fois la
fédération de russie messieurs labeouf
pour son hospitalité et pour
l'invitation de yang jussiê et pour
l'aide qu'ils accordent à notre pays
merci
donc pas cette question sera celle ce
délicieux lavrov ma première question
pourvu qu'ils peuvent donc lé photos que
vous avez transmis de votre collègue qui
part cela pourrait favoriser l' enquête
de l'explosion à beyrouth à ce qu'il y a
des diverses accusations
concernant
la racine de cette crise politique
actuelle qui est ici le permettez je
vais poser la question en arabe au
maroc de loisirs du
haut doubs ali a alimenté
la loire elle estime
qu en est il de la crise libanaise au
point de vue de certains pays du golfe
persique surtout l'arabie saoudite est
surtout étant donné que monsieur le
ministre garda qui a refusé de
démissionner y at il une médiation arabe
au internationale pour résoudre cette
crise
le
[Musique]
toucher
est
[Musique]
sûre il faut dire que le liban a
toujours eu de bonnes relations avec les
pays du golfe persique
mais maintenant nous avons toujours des
relations avec oman et qatar
le nord des émirats arabes unis
continuent de travailler et la situation
actuelle la crise actuelle peut être
résolu nous avons l'intention d'avoir un
dialogue
nous aspirons à le faire et nous sommes
persuadés que la question du monsieur
carnacki est exagéré et peut être
résolue il ya deux centres négociations
avec les pays du golfe persique c'est
quelque chose que nos espérances
en ce qui concerne la question sur les
images satellites je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure elles pourront aider
l'enquète je suis pas spécialiste mais
sur l'ordre du président poutine nous
avons
décidé d'honorer la demande du président
libanais michel aoun qui avait est donc
une roskosmos a fourni les images
satellites dont nous disposons qui
décrivent la situation dans port de
beyrouth
au printemps de l'année dernière c'est à
dire avant
l'explosion et puis les images de la
situation après et ce sont les images
satellites ce que nous avons et donc les
spécialistes doivent pouvoir
déterminer en fonction des destructions
observer ce qui s'est passé nous
espérons que les spécialistes au liban
peut-être avec l'aide d'autres collègues
étrangers pourront analyser ces images
et
et qui pourront dès que donc facilitée
l'anc est dans ce contexte de tensions
politiques poussé
pour les deux ministres première
question
la démarcation maritime entre le liban
et ses voisins avez vous évoqué cette
question
la russie participé aux hôtels aider à
résoudre cette question entre le livange
au liban et israël par exemple parce
qu'elle l'a participe à l'aménagement du
plateau continental
quels sont les progrès actuels
ce genre de projets seront réalisés
deuxième question vous avez parlé de ça
également c'est la question des réfugiés
syriens au liban y at il aujourd'hui un
mécanisme concret ou en accord bilatéral
pour faire en sorte que cette question
commence à bouger et quand on s'attarde
à la vague du retour des réfugiés
syriens dans leur pays merci bon nous
avons abordé brièvement la question
au cours de nos discussions
notamment fassions les discussions
autour d'eux des limites maritimes des
frontières maritimes
je sais que ces questions se poursuivre
aujourd'hui
il aura peut-être d'autres informations
qui sont fournis en ce qui concerne
l'extraction de pétrole et de gaz comme
je l'aï déjà dit nous avons des sociétés
russes qui travaillent d'autres
notamment novatek
qui fait de la prospection et de
l'extraction
et à l'intention de
poursuivre ses explorations sur le
plateau continental et notamment la
société roussneft qui détient un site de
stockage dans le port de beyrouth et il
y a déjà des blancs vous à fait concrète
de modernisation et d'extension de ce
site nous en avons parlé avec nos
collègues aujourd'hui et donc il ya des
mesures à prendre justement apprendre
rapidement pour
accélérer ce processus
dans
coopération avec les autorités
libanaises et la deuxième question était
oui sur les
réfugié j'ai déjà tout dit
malheureusement il ya un an exactement à
damas
il y avait la première
conférence sur le retour des réfugiés
les etats-unis et l'union européenne
ont fait des efforts absolument
démente pour saper cette conférence
parmi les il y avait des démarches très
dure vis-à-vis des pays qui devaient
participer à cette conférence qui ont
été entreprises de façon à faire en
sorte que cette conférence ne se fasse
pas donc il ya vu un chantage
et malheureusement qui a été un chantage
qui était qui a eu du succès et le
secrétaire général de l'onu a
refusé d'envoyer
la délégation prévue mais envoyer
simplement son représentant à damas
comme observateurs cette conférence et
c'est très regrettable
c'est une infraction grave aux normes du
droit international
alors que toutes les questions sur les
réfugiés doivent être
résolus avec l'ensemble des pays
impliqués
notamment dans le pays
dont les citoyens sont justement
réfugiés à l'extérieur
et pour
dire une litote je dirais que cette
attitude est
inacceptable et un rgo d'autant plus
qu'après à bruxelles l'union européenne
a convoqué sa propre réunion
qui d'ailleurs était
co présidée par le secrétaire général
à mon grand regret et à cette conférence
ils ont occupé une position qui consiste
consistait uniquement à collecter de
l'argent pour envoyer
ces fonds dans les camps de réfugiés au
liban en jordanie en turquie en egypte
sans du tout respecté les normes de
droit international il nous penchons
nous pensons aux objets qu'il faut
soutenir la république arabe syrienne
soutenir le liban les autres pays qui
accorde
un refuge à ces
réfugiés
et la plupart pour que la plupart où
sont actuellement la plupart des
réfugiés si nos collègues libanais sont
intéressés nous les soutiendrons bien
sûr parce que nous sommes convaincus que
la responsabilité qu'a le liban
puisqu'il est aussi
cinq cent mille palestiniens qui sont
présents dans le pays il ya les réfugiés
syriens et c'est un fardeau très lourd
pour le liban et j'espère bien que les
donateurs occidentaux
s'impliquant ici nous avons d'ailleurs
parlé aussi de la question du règlement
israélo-palestinien
nous avons un certain nombre de
préoccupations ici quand nous voyons que
ça ne
la situation n'avance par les
discussions directes entre les escales
est le plus nocif enfin le quatorze des
pays
ne se réunit pas il n'y a pas de
constatation de
n'y a pas d'avancée dans le dans ce
domaine et tout cela est pour nous une
source de préoccupation mais nous
maintenons notre intérêt
c'est nous soutenons près le président
mahmoud abbas nous sommes pour une
conférence sur ces questions et
notre temps nous avons proposé de mener
des rencontres des ministres des
affaires étrangères du quartet avec
l'implication des représentants des pays
arabes
avec des représentants des parties en
conflit
pour voir comment ça va ce moment cette
situation va évoluer et d'ailleurs au
cours de la visite demain le pressent de
sa visite à moscou demain le président
de l'autorité palestinienne
nous fera part de ses idées et nous dira
commence avant ce la situation et
notamment les discussions entre le fatah
et le hamas
la
loi
avant tout je voudrais commencer
par la question des réfugiés serrières
ii le retour ici une opposition la
motion russe et libanaises sont tout à
fait les mêmes mais il ya une opposition
de l'occident qui voient ce processus de
manière différente le liban est tout à
fait pour le retour le plus rapide dans
des refuges et dans leur pays étant
donné qu'il ya une une stabilisation qui
est en cours mais les pays occidentaux
le perçoivent autrement pour eux le
retour des réfugiés syriens permettrait
de renforcer d'une certaine manière le
régime de bachar al assad mais nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec cela deuxième
question porte sur les frontières
maritimes du liban israël
j'ai mis à
la milkil
energy la filiale
hwa
[Musique]
lesquelles la mi-aout bad
love you no man u 7 km
qui
concerne la démarcation des frontières
maritimes avec israël dans ce chenil
dans ce cas là le liban a des contacts
avec tous les partis toutes les parties
intéressées y lit armoire
représentants américains ont rendu
visite à notre pays
ceux qui sont responsables
de l'énergie dans le département
américain donc ils ont promis de
transmettre nos préoccupations et de
revenir avec leurs propositions
proposition malgré le fait qu'il y a eu
un certain temps déjà
nous n'avons pas eu du répondant sur
notre position et suivantes le liban
réclame milito
830 kilomètres carrés du territoire
maritime ans dépendamment de la forme de
cette partie c'était notre dernière
demande
montre à l'aise je veux pas boire je
suis là
monsieur de labour la mise au jeu des
questions pour vous
la première sur les investissements
ajoute est-ce que vos efforts conjoints
diplomatique et votre coopération
politique
on est des jeunes il faut lutter contre
les problèmes intérieurs et les facteurs
extérieurs de gaulle c'est ce qui fait
de ce qui existe il ya eu plusieurs
initiatives russes ont participé à la
restauration des infrastructures
libanaises
non seulement dans le travail sur les
gisements de novatek
et monsieur là vous faire une petite
précision à faire s'il vous plaît vous
avez parlé des réserves de pétrole dans
le port de beyrouth ce serait bien oui
mais si je comprends bien grosse tête à
signer
le contrat concernant le nord je ne
s'agisse ya encore des contrats de vente
comporte ou dans le port de beyrouth
parce que vos efforts conjoints ont aidé
à
surmonter tous les obstacles
extérieur
avec qu'on se mette bien plus brève que
votre question des déchets déjà parlé de
nos plans en matière de novatek et
rosneft
est ce que la contribution de ces
compagnies russes qui veulent travailler
dans ce domaine
permettra de coopérer de contribuer au
développement
du pays est-ce que cela servira les le
peuple et la prospérité je l'espère
laissez moi monsieur le ministre c'est
encore une question
votre 1ère visite
or c'est ce que je les bats donc vous
avez choisi la version d'office pour
cette visite
cette
diplomate avec mon stage de travail
énorme a diverti
ceci montre
les orientations de la politique
extérieure du débat
elle a réussi en tant que premier pays
de visiter
paris
la laque est
là
au final
nous ne faisons pas le jeu mis à douelle
que la magie le tarn doit l'image de
l'euthanasie notre cirque bits la
maladie
[Musique]
m'a donné ma salle à doha la
floride
m'a mis à nager
et là
bien sûr en répondant à cette question
je dois licht mentionnait que ce n'est
pas moi qui définit personnellement la
politique du débat il ya le gouvernement
de votre pays pour cela je suis arrivé
ici après avoir reçu l'ordre du premier
ministre et du président libanais
chemise est libre et ouvert à développer
toutes les relations avec tous les pays
du monde ont besoin de ces relations
nous essayons de les diversifier et bon
ma visite en russie aujourd'hui je ne
diminue pas l'importance non je veux
coopération avec les pays occidentaux
le liban a l'intention de voir un
dialogue avec absolument 12 n'était pas
ce qu'on veut selon notre pays cela va
permettre de stabiliser la situation
d'un autre pays
nous sommes tout à fait respectueux de
la position de ligands je tiens à dire
que contrairement aux pays occidentaux
ne
jamais à nos partenaires avec qui ils
doivent mener des négociations des
partenariats etc alors que les états
unis et les pays européens
insiste auprès de nombreux pays dans le
monde pour laure empêché de travailler
avec la russie et la chine c'est un fait
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas caché nous ne
faisons que jamais cela nous n'imposons
jamais de telles conditions nous
respectons la souveraineté
est le droit souverain de nos
partenaires de choisir leurs collègues
sur l'arène internationale de choisir
ceux avec lesquels ils veulent
travailler c'est tout
dernière qui sont basses bonjour
messieurs les ministres ma question est
pour ça qu est la preuve selon les
médias le crenna pour la première fois
qu'ils utilisaient les lances missiles
javelin dans le dos brasse messieurs
lavrov à moscou at elle des données sur
cette question et je vais t-il pas lieu
de craindre que cela va bouleverser la
situation dans le donbass la russie a at
elle l'intention d'avoir des contacts
avec les états unis concernant le cren
prochainement je n'ai pas entendu parler
de cela je n'ai vu aucun message à ce
propos
mais en principe
ces dernières semaines ces derniers mois
nous voyons une sorte de plus de
conscience justement de la part de des
autorités de kiev et notamment des
militaires
avec une situation
enflammé est exagéré et donc cette
rhétorique militaire belliqueuse va se
poursuivre elles manifestaient elle aura
le caractère de
provocation comme s'il cherchait à
vouloir aggraver les choses mettre de
l'huile sur le feu et le
commandant des forces kényanes et le
commandement des forces
présentes dans le donbass
propose un certain nombre de plans il y
avait un terme qu'on utilisait autrefois
en russe qui voulait dire que la chose
militaire
cissé s'il veulent employer des missiles
est déjà l'un des îlots ils ont déjà
utilisé les bailleurs acteurs
ils ont dit qu'ils n'ont pas fait par
hasard
parce que
c'est interdit c'est interdit par les
accords 2000 ce qu'ils étaient très
fiers de l'indien
après ils ont dit que c'est arrivé à
prison dit que ça n'était pas arrivé
mais après il se trouve que nous mais
ils étaient moins qu'ils allaient
continuer à utiliser des drones d'attac
crachant sur leurs obligations liées aux
accords de minsk
un autre exemple encore de cette
rhétorique
belliqueuse
disent que les ministères les militaires
ukrainiennes n'ont aucune restriction 30
heures les âges
des armements dans le débat c'est qu'ils
peuvent s'en servir comme ils le veulent
et donc cela
directement montre directement que le
crime aurait refusé
d'appliquer son engagement sur l'emploi
des armes et sur la façon de valider les
échanges je rappelle encore une fois
entre parenthèses que cette question
parmi d'autres
devaient être au coeur de la discussion
au format normandie avec nos camarades
français et allemand donetsk est
lougansk
remplissent leurs obligations
kiev son sort ce retrait se retirer
directement
ouvertement de ses obligations et
ne remplit pas ce qui était convenu est
donc encore une fois ils le font avec le
soutien des allemands et des français et
encore une fois c'est une impasse et qui
me préoccupe beaucoup cette obstination
avec laquelle paris et berlin ne veulent
pas soutenir
l'exécution des accords de minsk et qui
justifie de manière injustifiable
justement les agissements de kiev nous
avons déjà dit que pendant le sommet de
genève lé président poutine hebeisen
le président américain avait rappelé
l'attachement aux accords de mills qui
avait reconnu qu'il était nécessaire
de remplir toutes les parties des
accords qui concernent le statut de zone
basse
et quand nous avions victoria nuland qui
étaient ici elle avait eu des
discussions et avec confirmé 2 ce
qu'avait dit le président biden et donc
nous partons du principe que les états
unis
comprennent peut-être mieux
la situation actuelle
mais le fait qu'ils peuvent avoir une
influence sur kiev plus forte que les
autres pays personne n'a de doute là
dessus donc nous verrons bien comment
les états unis
respecteront tiendront leur parole et
pour que les accords 2000 soit enfin
respectée
j'estime qu'il est inné il n'est pas
nécessaire de créer de nouveaux formats
de discussion il ya un mécanisme qui
existe qui correspond
aux clauses de l'accord de m je veux
dire le comptable le groupe de contact
où travaillent directement donetsk
lougansk et kiev avec l'aide de l'eau et
se et de la fédération de russie
et exécuter toutes les obligations qui
découlent des accords de minsk tout cela
doit se faire précisément dans ce format
et lors d'un contact entre nos
présidents d'autres paramètres sont
examinés et je pense que bien évidemment
la question et chrétienne reviendra à
l'ordre du jour encore une fois nous ne
voyons pas la nécessité de mettre en
place de nouveaux formats et
l'administration précédente américaine
nous avions des contacts avec
son cas c'est
l'autorité des accords de minsk et
sont cassés les contacts qu'ils doivent
se faire entre
donetsk lougansk et qui est donc encore
une fois tout cela peut être utilisé
pour le bien et pour la paix je vous
remercie